قرار المحكمة وكل هذا في
يذكر أن الإسلام مشكلة
تقول الوزير أن أ
الدين مشكلة
[موسيقى]
من الشيطنة يكاد يكون
قليلا في العجلة أجدك
عليك أن تفهم الفيتامينات
أنت لست صعبًا بما يكفي لأجده هناك
التمييز بين ما السيد.
أتفق مع ما تقوله مدام لوبان
مارشال ما يقوله السيد كولارد أنا
حقًا سيقول فرقًا كبيرًا
بالفعل لدينا انت جاهز
إذا لم أفهمها بشكل صحيح
تشير إلى الطوائف وأنت تقول ذلك
الإسلام ليس مشكلة حتى
حقًا هذا الجزء بعيد بما فيه الكفاية على ما يرام
أتخيل أن يخيب آمال الكثير من الناخبين
سيدتي لذا أولا حتى الآن أنا
يعتقد أنه لم يكن هناك هجوم
شخصي وأنت لديك لي
هاجم شخصيا عدة مرات
في أي وقت قلت لي
قال أنه يعرف مشكلة إذا كنت
لا تسحب تصريحاته لي أنا أنت
رفع دعوى بالتشهير
[موسيقى]
حتى وزير لكم من
عادة ما يعتبر ويضمن
سلامة الأشخاص الذين تضع نفسك في مكانهم
يتعارض في خطر ولكن الفرنسية
اعتراف المرأة الفرنسية و
الفرنسيون ذوو العقيدة الإسلامية
التصويت على قانون الانفصال الذي يوصم بالعار
بعنف قسم كامل من المجتمع
وطنية برميها
[موسيقى]
الاعتداء الجسدي ضد
النساء اللواتي يرتدين الحجاب في المسجد
تاجيت أحرق ضريح المسجد أيضا
ذابل ثم كل هذا هو مجرد
نتيجة لك